كان هذا في يوم من الأيام منزل شخص ما مكانًا
يلعب فيه الأطفال وتتجمع العائلات
الآن ، تعمل هذه المجموعة من المتطوعين
بجد لاستعادة ما فقدته ، أشعر
أننا نجتمع حقًا
أنك موحد ، نعم
نحن معًا
ونعلم أنه منزلنا  ويدرك جميع
الأوكرانيين أننا بحاجة إلى
إعادة بناء
المئات الذين تم تسجيلهم للانضمام إلى أكثر من
اثنتي عشرة عملية تنظيف عبر
ضواحي كييف التي أطلقتها المجموعة الخيرية
بالمنطقة الأولى ، فنحن جميعًا مختلفون
لأن لدينا اهتمامات مختلفة حسب الأعمار ولكننا نعمل هنا معًا كأحد
سكان كولورادو الأصليين.  voll هو من بين أولئك الذين
يساعدون المبنى الذي نحن فيه
الآن قد تعرض للقصف من قبل الروس
ويجب أن يتم تغطية هذا من قبل أصحاب المنازل
أنفسهم ، لذلك من قبل كل هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
يخرجون ويساعدون حقًا في
بدء هذه العملية لهم.
أصبحت قرية ميلا الصغيرة خطًا أماميًا
بين عشية وضحاها عندما
انطلقت القوات الروسية نحو كييف وأطلقت النار بعنف على
المباني السكنية التي كانت في طريقها.
أشعلت النيران في سقف المبنى
ودمرت الطوابق العليا
وقتل المدنيون حتى أثناء فرارهم من
المقيمة ماريا بوبوفا شاهدنا
الرعب
الذي اختبأناه في الطابق السفلي
، وتقول إننا جلسنا وشاهدنا
منازلنا تحرق
القوات الروسية وقد انسحبت لكن
الدمار الذي لحق بهم  لقد تركت وراءنا
منازل رائعة تحطمت هنا في
لحظة ولكن إعادة بناء الحياة
ستستغرق وقتًا أطول
، وتلك جهود الإنعاش متروكة
للمجتمعات التي
يعمل بها جنود الجيش ونحن نعمل
لديهم وظيفة في الخطوط الأمامية نعم
لديك  العمل هنا أيضًا ، نعم
، كانت بوبوفا البالغة من العمر سبعة وسبعين عامًا هي
أول من عاد إلى المبنى ،
وقد نجت شقتها إلى حد كبير ،
وأعتقد أن جيشنا أخبرتني
أنه لا يوجد مكان مثل المنزل عندما تكون
في المنزل وتهدئك الجدران  تسقط الحرب التي
لم تكن بعيدة ، مجرد العيش في أوكرانيا يبدو
وكأنه عمل من أعمال التحدي